Four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
So what,
um,
hundred mile man or a hundred man,
what is it?
The 100 mile man.
What does that,
I ran a hundred mile race so years ago
and then say like,
I'm the fucking man,
let me,
let me grab it if it's available.
That's cool that you got it man.
Cause that's a very popular thing now.
Yeah.
Did you run this before or after you did
the book with David Goggins?
I ran it before.
Ah,
okay.
Yeah,
I think it's time when I did it.
They were like 400 Americans is,
they ran a hundred miles or something.
It wasn't a lot.
So that's why it was available.
Isn't it crazy how many people do it
now?
Yeah,
I think I was trying to figure out in my
head how many do it a year and like how
many races?
A hundred mile races there are there a
month and then multiply it out.
So probably five or 6,000 I'm guessing
five or 6,000 people who've done it?
I think probably.
I think so.
Wow.
Americans.
Yeah,
it's a long way.
It's a long fucking way.
We're just about talking right before
the podcast about how Miss America
yanked off,
uh,
all theirs.
They're no longer judge by their beauty.
And I post this because I thought it was
silly and there's just these fights
online,
man.
This fucking fights in the comments and
fights and people are tense.
Yeah.
People need to go out,
run those hundred miles.
But yeah,
they loosen up fast,
fast.
I don't,
what the fuck is going to miss?
America is scrapping the swimsuit
competition would no longer be judged on
physical appearance.
It's literally a beauty contest.
That is what it is.
What are they replacing it with?
I mean,
I got to think it's like when playboy
decided to not have people nude,
right?
That like the,
but here's the thing,
but no longer judging them on their
physical appearance.
But what does that mean?
What does that mean?
Yeah,
that's a two way.
No longer a pageant.
Gretchen Carlson says
we're competition.
Okay.
I give up.
I don't know.
I think that might have bee a bee of
hurt the ratings a little bit.
I think a little bit or not.
Maybe people will get very excited about
it.
Maybe a little ramp up.
Yeah.
It's getting a lot of talk.
Maybe people will be pissed off and so
they'll tune in.
It's just,
I don't know.
Where do you stand on it?
I don't give a fuck.
It's so stupid.
Miss America.
I mean,
this is what's really fascinating to me
is that,
uh,
it was a read in the comments.
A lot of feminists were angry at me that
I was Maki and I saw a few of them.
I don't get it.
Like,
why would you even want a who I'd most
like to fuck contest because that's what
it is.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
You haven't these gals parade around or
bikini.
It's a beauty contest.
Do we have a Mister America contest?
Like is that just the president?
Is that what the Mr American context is?
I Dunno.
I mean,
I was,
I was trying to ask you as someone who's
deeply connected to competition
and mindsets,
yeah.
I don't know.
I'm not following it that closely,
but I am going to miss that part of the
competition even though really I just,
there's so many opportunities to see
people naked today.
They,
yeah.
But you know,
as a kid watching the met Miss America
pageant,
I was like,
you know,
they weren't allowed to options back
then.
Yeah.
Kids today are broken sports illustrated
and dust pageant swimsuit issue.
I wonder if they're gonna continue to
swimsuit issue.
Hmm.
Maybe the,
just see their faces and just have to
assume they're in this swimsuit and then
you know,
there'll be like a bubble,
a thought bubble and it will be filled
with an amazing quote that they say
that'd be the new swimsuit issue.
Cause we're just judging them on their
minds.
Right.
And the content.
Yes.
The content,
the content.
Speaking to content,
living with monks.
Yes.
What is it called?
Living with the monks.
Um,
does your new book?
Yes.
Why did you start to do that and how
long did you do it for?
I did it for 15 days.
I was enough.
That's more than enough,
man.
Yeah.
We're going to go like this for an hour.
Your finger all fall off dealing with
your finger up and down.
Just a repetition.
What did you have to do?
I uh,
well I live with,
there were,
there were eight monks for which had
been there for 50 years,
50 50 on a monastery,
800,
500 acres kind of in the middle of
nowhere.
And um,
I went for 15 days.
So I figured,
you know,
I,
I'd invested so much of my life on the
physical side and ran a hundred miles
and just always active and this and that
and have really invested very little on
my own inner work.
And I just felt like,
man,
I just felt overwhelmed a little bit.
And I said to my wife,
you know,
who are the masters and everything
pointed to monks and I said,
I want to go live on a monastery.
There's something romantic about that,
right?
It's almost like the guy who goes off
into the woods to write a book.
I like being with a,
with a monk like and just being,
you know,
in a monastery with monks.
There's something very romantic about
that.
Right.
Does it,
you've shared all your worldly
belongings and you no longer care about
the day to day nonsense that everybody's
fixated on.
Just decide to just,
Oh,
[inaudible]
yes.
Oh,
all day.
You could do it.
I don't want to do it,
man.
You should want to do it.
I've lived the opposite of amongst life.
My life is filled with bullshit.
I get it.
Yeah.
Where'd you go?
So I went,
I went to a monastery just south of
Canada in the states.
Ah,
yeah.
But no,
what state is it?
It was in upstate New York.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
like on the Vermont border and it was
um,
you know,
no phone total kind of separation from
my family.
I have four kids,
my wife,
and just got to,
uh,
get to know myself little bit.
Wow.
Now when you were up there,
was there any time where you're like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Like one minute into it.
I got when I first got up there,
the main monk,
like my goto monk,
brother,
brother Christopher took me to my room.
They call the rooms a cell,
which is about the size of this table.
And I had a bed.
I walked in,
there was a bed,
there was a little desk with a night
lamp on it and nothing on the walls.
And he said,
tomorrow we're going to start prayer,
reflection and meditation at 7:15 AM and
I looked at my watch and it was 6:00 PM
and I asked him,
well,
what do we do between now and 7:15 AM?
And he looked at me dead in the eye and
he said,
you think?
And I said to myself,
I'm fucked.
Because I'm like,
I don't really like spend a lot of time
in thought.
So I went and I said,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to meditate.
You know,
like I'm here.
Let me start this journey with
meditation.
I'd taken a little a course in
transcendental meditation.
I'm not a big meditation guy other than
running.
And so I set my timer for 20 minutes and
I sat down in my chair and I started
like focusing on my mantra.
Like immediately I'm bombarded with how
is my wife,
how the kids,
the hawks,
all this,
you know,
the Atlanta Hawks.
I look at the ladder like,
you know,
and not,
you're kind of hawk,
everything's coming at me.
And um,
you know,
time is going by and I'm just getting
bombarded with thought and I'm like,
why isn't my timer buzz like it's been,
I've been here forever.
So I was going to look and reset my
thing and I'm like,
that would be cheating.
Let me keep going and going.
And all the time's going by.
And finally I'm like,
fuck is going on with my time or you
know.
So I opened my eyes and I looked to
reset my timer.
It's three minutes and 27 seconds.
No,
and I said to my,
I like really thought it was 20 minutes.
I thought it was like hours,
man.
I mean like I'd never really sat in a
room like with nothing going on and just
closed my eyes alone and thought and
time to stop.
And I calculated how much time I have
left,
like 15 days times,
24 hours,
a 60 minutes.
And I said to myself like,
man,
I'm in trouble.
This isn't like,
like this isn't what I'm on Gilligan's
island.
This is a real like I can't get out of
here.
And I,
I had a really hard time with it.
What was the commitment?
The commitment was 15 days.
So the only you,
it was a personal feeling.
Did it up to you like there was no,
nothing in writing.
And did you have a way to escape?
I mean I was thinking of escape plans,
but I'm on the monastery and this is a
little crazy that the way the monks keep
the lights on is they breed German
shepherds.
That's how they make money.
They breed German shepherds are,
the largest I've seen is they wrote a
book,
they wrote a book.
I have the book.
It's a book about raising puppies.
Correct.
The same guys.
Same guys.
Oh,
so they weren't Buddhist.
They were Russian Orthodox and they
raise German shepherds.
So they live on this property and there
are these 11 German shepherds,
and at the end of the property,
the only way off the property where two
mobile homes unconnected to the
monastery at the end of this road that
leads up to the monastery.
And both of those homes had German
shepherds as well that were a little
territorial.
So there really was no way for me to
escape.
Like I couldn't,
I ran 120 miles up and down the driveway
while I was there because I couldn't
leave the property.
So you just timed herself or paced
yourself using an APP or something?
I said like 2000 steps equals a mile.
Counted your steps.
Oh,
Jesus Christ,
dude.
Yeah.
I counted it and marked it to,
what did they think about you running
around back and forth like that?
Thought it was a fucking psychopath.
I'm like,
you guys have been here for 50 years,
man.
I'm just trying to get some extra sales.
What are the,
the guys like that had been there for 50
years?
Uh,
quiet now.
They were,
they were,
you know,
extremely listened to date.
They were doing what they wanted to do
with their life.
So they were super happy.
Really?
Yes,
super present.
I mean very present and I mean I live in
a world that to do list man and like,
you know,
they were very present,
very happy and really,
really nice to me.
And everybody.
Did you talk to them?
They speak English.
What was the conversation like?
Like what,
what,
what do you say to a guy who's been in a
monastery for 50 years?
Just staring at the walls while I
wanted,
if I could have talked to him about the
pageant,
that would have been just a conversation
he brought,
I know,
super confused.
Uh,
when I first got up there and they would
ask me a little bit about my background.
I told them,
you know,
how's in the private jet business?
They didn't understand private jets
really?
And then I said,
I had a coconut water company.
They never heard of coconut water.
I told them I was involved with the
Atlanta Hawks and one of the monk said,
Oh,
I've been to a an expos game.
And I'm like,
that's a different sport and they don't
play,
they don't exist anymore.
And this is very like timewarp at first.
It was really interesting,
really interesting.
Jesus.
Now what led these,
these guys that are 50 years,
50 years on the Montessori,
how old were they?
Uh,
so some of the,
the age range from,
I think the youngest monk was probably
35 up until late seventies.
So late seventies with the guys that had
been there for 50 years.
They checked in when they were 20.
Yeah,
in their young twenties in the same
spot.
They actually built this monastery by
hand.
They bought 500 acres for very,
you know,
I think it was like $50,000 or
something.
I mean,
something crazy.
And then they built the monastery by
hand.
And so it's been a passion of love and
labor and they've been there since.
And so the vow of celibacy,
the whole deal and poverty,
poverty,
insolvency at 20.
Yeah.
They,
they take a vow for things of um,
celibacy.
Poverty's,
they pledge all their personal
belongings to the monastery.
So really they're only possession is a
driver's license.
Obedience and stability.
Meaning we're not leaving.
This is what we're going to do.
So I mean talk about discipline just off
the charts to do forever.
Forever.
And where do they get funding?
They're self sufficient.
So they stay breeds German shepherds,
they sell them.
That's kind of one income stream.
And then their master's world masters of
dog training training.
So every two weeks they have 10 dogs
that come in and they,
and I've watched this,
I mean they literally dogs come in like
spuds Mackenzie and leave.
Like they just left etiquette school.
Like it was like anytime you're in the
presence of the people that are the best
in the world,
that what they do,
it's fucking fascinating.
And these guys were masters.
They are the masters of,
I'm sure there's a lot of people that
are great but in their space of dog
training and breeding,
what was so special about the way they
trained dogs?
Just the command,
like,
like they had an energy that the dogs
responded to.
I mean like I would walk in and the dogs
would go crazy.
They'd sniff my nuts.
They just like,
they go nuts,
right?
These guys would walk in and like they
could just sense that they were in
control,
they were in control and like the eye
contact that they,
everything,
the way that they talk,
their tone,
their hand mannerisms,
they just have mastered this and they
have a deep connection with the dogs.
Dogs are weird in that way.
Like I have a one year old golden
retriever and he has different rules for
different people and he knows who he can
get away with.
What with uh,
my wife's mom has zero shot at
controlling this dog.
Like,
it's like,
he's like,
ah,
no,
no.
I'm the boss.
I think I'm going to jump up on you and
kiss.
Yeah.
You know?
No,
I'm going to just run around and put a
pause on you when you sit in a chair and
you know,
we're like,
Marshall,
come on man.
What the fuck?
What is this?
You don't do this?
And it doesn't matter when she's here.
He just decides Mac new set of rules
with this lady.
She doesn't seem to know what the fuck
to do with me.
But when,
uh,
I had a trainer that I worked with him
for in the beginning when I first got
him and when Ryan,
the trainer comes over,
he just like sits down,
he's super chill,
he listens.
He's like,
Oh,
this guy knows what the fuck to do.
Yeah,
he knows how to control me.
It's,
it's very interesting.
He's even different with me than he is
with my friends.
Like my friends will come over.
It's like,
let me try you out,
motherfucker,
pause on you and see what's up.
And I wish she would be like across the
board with everybody.
But he's just,
it's all love.
So it's not bad,
you know,
he's just a you dog.
Yeah,
well it's just like pause on you and
shit.
You know?
And I'm not really a dog person and I
like dogs,
but don't have one.
No,
no.
But we don't really connect.
You don't connect with it.
Not,
not like instant love when they see me
the way that they are with other people,
you know,
but the monks were using that were
teaching me various lessons,
almost like karate kid style through the
dogs.
So like the first day I got there every
day I was signed to a different role
with,
I would shadow one of the monks and
there were eight and they had different
responsibilities around the monastery.
The first day I was in the training
center with one of the most,
it was training the dog and then my job
was to be the distractor.
So rainbow,
this dog would walk around and I would
fucking go adam and jump and run and
like try to,
you know,
whatever,
get him to break his goal of going.
They were kind of simulating a park
scene or a city scene and making this
dog not get distracted.
So I would go nuts with the pork chop
and this and throw it,
whatever.
The dog would just go unwavering from
point a to point b.
And the monk said to me at the end,
just like,
it's just like life man.
He's like,
if you have a
goal,
just like rainbows goal is to get from a
to B,
you can't be distracted in your goal.
And I was like,
that makes sense.
Some karate kid stuff,
like I'm like mock song.
Yeah.
Like wax on and,
but all these different lessons started
to emerge.
It was pretty interesting.
Wow.
So that,
that isn't just,
it's,
it's interesting too that they're doing
it with German shepherds are really,
really smart dogs.
I want like,
what's a dumb dog?
Uh,
what's like a generally thought of
downward dog?
Let's think.
Trying to think like what would
generally be thought of as a dumb dog.
There's no like,
yeah,
prejudices for dogs,
right?
Is there,
this is like,
well,
like one breed or like this dumb fucking
breed.
I don't think of like when you say like
a dumb dog,
this dumb individual dogs,
but I don't ever think of like,
oh,
that there's some dogs that are like
spastic,
right?
Like Jack Russell terriers are kind of
spastic,
but that's because they were raised to
kill rats and they just like,
they have high kill drive and they're
super hyper.
Like,
I can't think of a dog that's supposed
to be stupid,
but German shepherds are generally
supposed to be smart with English
bulldogs,
but I don't know if that's really true.
I think they're just lazy,
man.
My dog,
brutus is half English bulldog and half
Sheebu.
He know he just has bad joints and he's
just lazy.
He's just,
I don't think he's stupid.
Yeah,
it's kind of a dick.
He said Dick to other dogs,
but I just think that's because he's in
pain a lot.
These dogs were super smart.
They're so smart,
man.
Those dogs look at you and they're
little.
They're sizing you up,
checking you out,
see what the fuck you're up to.
Make sure you're cool,
but there's like this feeling like they
know they could kill you,
like they're looking at you like,
I could kill you,
but I'm just checking you out.
I had that feeling that they could kill
me too.
Yeah.
It's a real feeling.
Yeah,
they can and they were like,
I was scared.
They were sensing that he's trying to
like down.
Downplay my fear.
Yeah.
My friend who trains them has a,
a dog that's like,
he does police work and it's like a
serious fucking dog and he'll attack
like a thing.
If you're holding like a stick,
like on command and he jumps and one of
the things he does,
he bites the stick and then to pause,
go right into your nuts.
And I don't think it's on purpose,
but damn,
it's an effective strategy.
Like it's like bite and then nuts stomp
all in one maneuver.
Right?
Yeah.
But those dogs are,
you know,
they're uh,
they're a dog that's sort of bread and
designed for protection work and police
work and stuff.
Yeah,
they are.
And they train their dogs as pets.
So they didn't do any kind of,
you know,
police work or anything like that.
So that the 11 German shepherds that
were on the property was super well
behaved.
I mean,
like ridiculously well behaved.
So when they train them or they're just
training them to make sure that they're
obedient,
you know,
they just listen,
watch the house,
bark at strangers,
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
Hand signals obedient,
you know,
not jumping,
but really that,
you know,
they know who's in control.
So did these guys do that before they
started running the monastery or was it
something that they decided to do while
they had the monastery?
No.
So they,
uh,
they fell into it.
They didn't go up there.
They,
none of them had any experience in dog
training.
Uh,
that wasn't the intent.
They just said,
we've got to keep the lights on here.
And they had a dog,
they had a dog as a pet and fell in love
with a dog.
And ultimately they,
when the dog passed away,
they all got killed.
Uh,
they wanted another dog and they went to
a breeder and they got two dogs and they
actually just,
they realize that they,
you know,
once they bred an amazing puppy,
I lived their first litter that and
train these dogs that there was demand
and they just scaled it like any other
business,
you know,
and they learned along the way,
trial and error,
just like any entrepreneur.
I mean,
these guys will like,
first of all,
they were monks in there.
They're super spiritual.
They're religious,
they were Russian Orthodox,
they weren't in Buddhist.
And um,
but they're amazing entrepreneurs.
I mean like they ran this thing super
efficiently,
but the point would only be to make
enough money to keep the lights on.
Correct.
So as an entrepreneur,
it's almost like they're,
they're,
they're limited in their ambition.
I think excess,
you know,
it's not like they're,
if they have excess money and revenue,
it's not going to material things,
but it's for the life and the extension
of them,
of the monitors monastery,
they would save it and put it away for
taxes or what have you.
Yeah.
Or they have,
you know,
they're in the hands of God.
They have,
they don't have a lot of litters or they
don't have a lot of puppies or they have
no income.
Right,
right.
That's fascinating.
Now these guys,
what do they do for recreation?
Uh,
they pray Jesus,
they think they read,
what do they read?
And they have like an amazing collection
of books,
fiction,
everything really super low red.
So they do have some entertainment in
terms of like fiction.
Yeah.
And you know,
periods of it.
And I went up there with no expectation.
The only,
like I had heard of monks,
I watched,
I've seen monks in movies and read
articles and blogs,
but I never,
I didn't know much about it,
about the culture,
certainly about Russian Orthodox and the
different factions and this and that.
Um,
so I went up there,
eyes wide open and um,
but I,
I went up there really just to detach
and get away from feeling overloaded and
feeling distracted.
And Man,
I'm a father of four and I have a
business and my wife has an entrepreneur
and Sandra and I just wanted to see
like,
you know,
it's is Kinda my been my journey.
I learned best by diving into the
unknown,
just like I did with Dave.
And it just says,
I,
I've done in businesses and other
things,
it's just like I learned best by going
into the unknown.
So I didn't do a lot of research around
them or how they made money or this or
that.
I just kind of showed up.
Wow.
That's a,
it's a crazy undertaking.
But I guess if you knew you only had 15
days,
at least you have like some light at the
end of the rain,
but when that 15th Day came and what did
you get in a car and drive away from
that place?
Yeah.
How fucking good did it feel?
Did you check your phone?
Just felt really on data.
What's going on on twitter?
I'm on day four and five.
I was already kind of making excuses.
I was rationalizing in my head that's
seven days would be enough.
So like in my head I was going home day
seven.
Oh,
well,
I mean I was like,
no one's going to know the difference or
care if I went 15 days or seven days or
is not like if you're at mile 50 and
you're like,
that's enough.
It is.
Same kind of thing.
Same kind of thing until you wake up the
next day and you're like,
I dropped out.
Right.
And you feel like,
you know,
so,
um,
anyway,
I decided like,
you know,
I'm going to stick this out.
And then when I left it was a,
it was a good feeling.
And the feeling was proud.
I felt proud of myself for sticking
through it.
You know?
Isn't that funny?
These guys had been there for 50 years.
50 years,
man.
And you're like,
I did two weeks,
man.
It felt good.
I bet it's it.
It also felt good to go through a bed.
Well,
it's the 50 years when you're describing
that.
That seems so insane to me that I can't
even relate.
But when you're talking about your 15
days,
I'm like,
man,
you poor bastard.
Like I feel bad for you.
The guy that 50 50 years,
he might as well be living in another
dimension.
Yeah.
As far as I'm concerned.
I went in there and it's twenties that
is just so nothing,
no sex,
no family,
no,
no neighborhood.
Nope.
No fucking hobbies.
No drive to work.
Nope.
Fuck.
And you know their,
their impression of it is like,
we made this decision so it's not,
we didn't sacrifice it like we decided
this is the life we want to live.
But when he made this decision,
it was 19 what?
or some shit.
That's just black and white tvs.
Oh my God,
that's a crazy decision.
That's crazy too to decide back then.
Like I,
I,
I see what's coming and I've had enough,
I've had enough these daily newspapers.
It's just too much information.
Right,
exactly.
That's a crazy time to check out.
So they don't know what the fuck's going
on in the world.
Did you quiz them on shit,
I didn't really quiz them.
I mean,
they,
every Sunday night they have one,
there's one TV and one back room and
they watch the news.
So they get a sense of just like,
you know,
kind of where we are.
State of the Union war.
If there's a nuclear meltdown.
Yeah.
One hour.
Uh,
yeah.
They watch about an hour on Sunday
night,
one night a week.
And that's how the tuner who do they
crazy.
I was immediately like,
my head went to like,
I'm sure we're being attacked right now
and I'm stuck at the monastery.
I'm sure the airlines are flying and I'm
stuck here for another 30 days.
Right.
No,
my mind went to a place where I was
thinking just the worst of everything.
You know,
what news do they trust?
Uh,
I think they trust it all,
but like which channel do they go to?
Oh,
they would just watch like,
you know,
uh,
the local ABC,
see the local network,
whatever's local in upstate New York.
They weren't Netflix options.
Do they have internet?
Uh,
I had no access to the Internet and I
think they have access probably for
their job,
but I didn't know actually.
So the dog training Jesus Christ,
it was wild.
But why is that so romantic to people?
Because it is,
it's a very romantic,
right?
There's something about this idea of
checking out.
It's just,
I had a buddy who did it.
I mean,
for all I know,
he still does it.
I lost touch with them 25 plus years
ago,
but he was a taekwondo guy and he
started to meditate because he was
always very nervous about sparring and
very nervous about competition.
So excuse me.
He was trying to figure out what was
going on.
So he said,
let me just take some meditation
classes.
It took some meditation classes and
really enjoyed it,
got really,
really into it.
And then one day decided to give up all
the worldly possessions and all of the
trappings of civilization and move into
the monastery.
And I remember we went,
we met him for lunch one day,
he'd also become a vegetarian.
So you only ate vegetables and we were
all just hanging around and he,
he seemed oddly a piece and it was so
confusing to me because at the time I
was like probably 20 and I was just
didn't know what the fuck is going on in
the world.
He was maybe 10 years older than me and
this guy just decided I've had enough.
It was weird to me though.
He made me nervous.
Like,
you know,
like he made me nervous that like he was
onto something.
It may be nervous that he wiser
than me,
that it highlighted how fucked up I am.
And you know,
especially at 20 years,
it's so life is so chaotic,
right?
No idea what the future holds for you.
If it's going to be success or failure,
if you're going to slip it every fucking
banana peel you run across.
But he seemed to have it figured out,
sitting there and eating vegetables,
all common shit.
Where's he now?
I have no idea.
I lost touch with them.
I lost touch with them,
you know,
probably like 30 years ago.
But,
uh,
when I was 20,
those guys freaked me out too.
They must've freaked you out just when
you did this book.
I mean,
I freaked them out.
Really?
I was an alien and I came in there high
energy,
you know,
Rah Rah and like,
he's the only guys ever done that.
Uh,
probably probably at this particular
place,
I think for an extended period of time.
Like that.
Yeah.
Wow.
What w w why did they let you do it?
Well,
that I had written a book,
Pryor,
uh,
living with a seal and they knew I was
coming up there to write a book.
And,
uh,
I guess they liked the first book.
Well,
I'm sure it be good for the dog business
too.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So they read your book,
they read my book.
Were you allowed to read books while you
were there?
I was allowed to.
I brought,
uh,
I'm not like a big reader,
so I figured two books would carry me
for 50,
for 15 days.
But I read them,
I read both in like the first day,
like the first two days.
Cause Yeah.
So then I was like a check whatever they
have.
Oh look,
Mary poppins.
Yeah.
I read this stupid shit.
I said I'm good.
Just thinking.
Wow.
So was there any point at like day 13
when you're like,
I actually Kinda liked this?
Yes.
I think around day seven and once I
realized like,
you know,
I got the excuses out of my head that
I'm staying,
I'm not,
I'm not leaving.
I mean this,
this is what I'm doing.
And I settled into it.
I got tremendously energized because
like at the monastery,
you don't make any decisions.
Do you eat when they tell you to eat,
you eat what they tell you to eat.
You go to service.
When the Church Bell Rings,
you go [inaudible] one outfit.
I showered once.
So all of these,
all the decisions were taken away from
you.
But when all the decisions are taken
away from you,
it frees up so much energy.
So I was getting like super clear and I
was like,
I like this.
This is like no one could get to me.
I'm not getting bombarded.
No one can schedule appointments with
me.
Hmm.
This isn't so bad.
Have you ever done a sensory deprivation
tank?
[inaudible] there's
the thing about the sensory deprivation.
You know what it is,
right?
The thing that's most interesting about
it is that in the absence of input,
your brain is freer and you can make
decisions better and think about things
better because there's no input coming
in.
You don't think about it.
But as we're sitting here just touching,
this table is input.
You are not looking at each other across
the lights.
All of this is input.
And in that tank there's no input.
And in the absence of input,
it frees up more resources for your
brain.
So in a sense,
what these monks you're saying or doing
by having everything on a schedule,
you don't have to think about anything
and there's nothing coming in.
There's no twitter,
facebook,
all that jazz.
You're,
you have more resources.
Correct.
And he feel better.
That's exactly it.
That's exactly right.
And I experienced that,
you know,
I think the average American makes like
35,000 to 50,000 decisions a day.
And there's a real thing called decision
fatigue.
Really?
Yeah.
And when you eliminate all,
like I remember when I came home,
I came home and the day I got home,
my wife is like,
Sweetie,
I'm going to take the kids to school and
I'm gonna take the blue car.
I was like,
cool,
take the blue car.
And she came back a minute later.
He's like,
you know what?
I don't think the other car,
because I want to park in the blue cars
too big.
And I was like,
I could take the other car.
And then she came back in,
she goes,
you know what,
I'm going to take the blue car because
I'm like,
Sarah,
you're using so much energy or already
it's 7:45 AM on what car to drive.
And I realized like,
that happens all the time.
You know,
it's like exhausting,
man.
And you,
I'm sorry,
go on.
No,
no,
I'm just saying like when you know,
I didn't have any of that.
So it freed up all this energy.
I'm not just making like massive life
lists what I want to do.
I became very aware of my relationship
with time.
I mean when we think of relationships,
we think of our relationships with our
mom or a dad or a kids or this and that.
But like no one thinks of a relationship
with time.
Now I'm turning 50 the average American
lives to be 78 years old.
So if I'm average,
I hope I'm not,
but that means I got 28 years of life
left.
If you reverse engineer that,
if you reverse engineer it,
you know like I just climbed Mt.
Washington,
I don't know,
70 year olds climbing Mount Washington,
the act,
the actual years that you have left to
be active and do the shit that we want
to do.
They shrink significantly as a
percentage as you get older.
So once you get aware of your
relationship with time,
everything shifts.
And I had a fundamental shift when I
came home with,
as it relates to my relationship with
time and who I want to spend it with and
what I want to do.
And I want to put more on my plate of
the stuff that I love to do with the
people I love to do it with.
And I started getting like a lot of
clarity around that when I wasn't
getting bombarded with everything else.
Like I don't spend any time alone.
The only time I spent a loan as when if
I go for a run,
everything else is I'm getting
influenced by everybody else and
everything else.
So I'm losing my main superpower,
my instinct to survive.
I've got a 90 on my sat man.
I survive on instinct and gut and I was
losing that because I was so distracted.
So once I started to get that alone time
and you have to go to a monastery to do
it,
you just gotta,
you know,
carving out a little bit of time for
myself every day I just started to think
a lot clearer on like you,
how do I want to live?
Reverse engineer the rest of my life.
Wow.
Do you think this is something that you
would do on a regular basis?
No,
but um,
it's something that I have and I feel
like,
you know,
like I said,
like going into the unknown,
it gives you an edge,
you know,
it gives you,
you come out of it a little bit
different than you go in.
It doesn't have to be a monastery.
He could be a race,
it could be business experience,
like whatever.
Right.
But just doing something different,
doing it different because you know,
um,
so yeah,
I feel like it's,
I don't think I would do it again,
but I don't think I have to because I
already have.
I can tap into that when I need it.
Do you dental where off though?
Cause a lot of times inspiration for
people.
It's,
it's fleeting.
The takeaways won't,
won't wear off.
Like I'm already back on my phone,
I'm back in modern day life.
You know,
I'm all fucked up again.
But the main things like my relationship
with time and certain things of,
you know,
who I want to spend there with.
And what I want to do and continuing to
build what I call my life resume,
doing these things to build up my,
not my business resume,
but my life resume.
That's things that I know I want to do
more of and that will never go away.
So,
you know,
um,
there's,
there's things that came out of it that
will last forever.
Like what kind of adjustments did you
make when you came back?
Started saying no.
Started praying.
I just,
I reversed engineered my life.
So let me give you an example.
My parents are
88.
Okay.
I have a good relationship with my
parents.
My parents are 88.
They live in Florida.
I see my parents,
let's say my parents lived to be 92.
I hope they live longer,
but let's say,
let's say they live five years,
right?
I don't have five years left with my
parents.
I see my parents twice a year.
That means I have 10 visits with my
parents.
So when I started to look at Shit like
that,
I made significant changes.
Like,
okay,
I'm gonna get on a plane and see my
parents.
And when I'm in those moments,
my feet are on the ground.
That's where I am because I only have a
limited amount of time with them.
You understand?
It's like it's not five years people
like,
oh I got five more now.
You know how many times you see him,
man,
you see him two times a year you've got
10 visits.
So I,
I just started looking at stuff like
that and became really aware when I'm in
moments that are big moments to take it
in and take note of it.
So it has an impact on me and I
appreciate it.
Wow.
Did you,
did you shift anything else in your
life?
Like as far as like what you do with
your time during the days I did.
So,
you know,
I started putting parameters around
simple things like my phone.
So like I was the guy at the movie
theater.
I'd be checking my young,
forgot the bing,
I'd like look under my shirt so the
light doesn't light up and know what you
know.
Well I'm glad at least you did that
courteous.
Yeah,
that's true.
But I put parameters,
you know,
nothing I'm not keeping my phone in at,
at,
at nighttime.
And you know,
seeing anything come in at five in the
morning,
nothing at the dinner table with my
kids.
So like basic,
obvious things like that.
But as far as my time,
I made two really big changes.
One changes,
and I kind of always been doing this,
so I wouldn't necessarily say it was a
change,
but I take three hours a day for myself
religiously every day.
Like I literally,
he's new just since the monster.
It's,
it's,
it's kind of like,
um,
it's unwavering since the monastery.
It's kind of been in my life and add in
my life,
but I just made a pie chart of time.
It's 24 hours in a day.
We all have the same pie chart.
It starts the same.
And I said,
all right,
I sleep seven hours.
I mean,
sometimes I'm out of balance with them
doing something big and put right now
six or seven hours.
I take three for myself and it's
cumulative.
So like I'll take,
could be,
I'm going to go for an hour run.
I'm gonna sit in the Sauna for 20
minutes,
I'm going to do fucking nothing.
But when I'm in my time,
I'm not mad that I'm not with my kids or
my wife or,
or I'm not mad that I'm not at my
office.
Like that's my time and when I'm with my
kids,
I'm not mad that I'm not at work or
whatever cause I don't want to resent my
wife from my boss or anybody for taking
away the shit that I love to do.
Like if they said you can't run,
you can't go in the sauna,
I'd be really pissed off.
I'd be pissed at my wife.
I'd be pissed at everybody.
So I take three hours for myself.
The average American works 40 hours a
week.
That's eight hours a day.
You still have six hours left in the
day.
Now of course you have to eat,
you have to commute,
you got family and this and that.
But my point is even take 24 hours is a
long day.
I learned that running,
you can get a lot of shit done if you
keep moving for 24 hours.
Even if you take three hours for
yourself,
if you get rid of the stuff that doesn't
move the needle in the buckets that are
most important to you,
you can get a lot done.
So I take three hours for myself and
that's been a,
you know,
and I'm not mad about it.
I'm not like guilty about it at all.
I feel like I'm way out of balance.
And then the second thing actually
didn't come from the monastery,
but it was like kind of an offshoot of
the monastery.
I was mentioned to you that I climbed
Mount Washington.
Now Washington's,
um,
in the winter is one of the 10 most
dangerous mountains.
I think the climb certainly in the
states has the highest death rate
because the winds are go up to about
anywhere from on any given day,
50 to a hundred miles an hour minus 35
degrees.
No visibility to fucking,
it's just a hundred miles an hour.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that like?
It's,
I mean,
I had an experience a hundred,
but I experienced super high winds.
Like when did you experience 50?
I think need more 50.
60.
Yeah.
What does it look like?
Well,
the first I went twice,
the first time I went to do it,
um,
I didn't make it to the summit because
it was too dangerous.
A T I actually timed out like I don't
have enough time to get back to make it
an altitude.
Uh,
no,
just in the amount of darkness,
darkness,
they would just gotten too too,
too tough to get back down.
I was with five friends,
no tour guide.
I mean did everything wrong.
Right.
And I actually came home after that
attempt,
which was a year ago,
and I was talking to my wife about it
and I was getting,
I posted it on facebook so everybody was
blasted.
You make it,
you know,
not Washington is only about four or
five,
five miles to the top,
4.6 miles.
Just the elements in the weather that
make it so hard.
And I said to my wife,
I failed.
You know,
like I didn't make it.
I feel like an ass.
I'm so disappointed.
You know,
I want to go back.
And she said,
well,
get a tour guide,
break in your boots,
properly trained for this and go back
next winter and check it off your list.
And I was like,
next winter,
I'm going back on Saturday next winter.
Like who knows if I'm going to be
healthy it off next winter.
So I went back next winter,
I mean that Saturday with the same guys.
And we did it.
And then recently this year I took my
son who's eight,
not to the top,
but we're like,
we're going to go camp out.
I want you to experience this,
got them a minus 40 sleeping bag and all
this stuff.
And we went out there with,
my friend is a police officer and
Suffolk County.
He brought his daughter and we're
sitting on out there sleeping outside,
fucking freezing,
fucking freezing and I'm all bundled up.
And I turned to him and I'm like,
Kevin,
how often do you do shit like this?
You know,
he's a police officer,
he's the happiest guys,
rock star shape.
And he goes,
I call it the Kevin rule.
He goes every year.
I go on one trip a year with my college
roommates been doing since I'm 21 and
then once every two months I take a
weekend and I do something.
I go camping.
I would run a marathon,
I'll go hiking,
I'll go to whatever with my family or
friends.
And I said to myself,
if I can't,
going back to your question about time,
if I can't take a weekend,
every eight weeks,
once every two months,
if I can't carve out a day or two to
take some kind of adventure to put on my
life resume or to have collected a
moment for me,
then my life is out of balance.
I call it the Kevin rule.
And I said,
if I live 30 more years,
if I live to 80 and I do that,
you know,
for 30 years it's 150 or a hundred
basic,
150 more fucking amazing memories that
I'm going to create.
And that became another one of these
time-related monastery related urgency
rules.
So I just,
again,
it just became a real big clarity around
like,
man,
I want to live with urgency and I want
to do as much shit as I can and put as
much on my plate of this stuff.
I love to do with the people I love in
my life and have it on my resume and
that's how I want to live my life
forward.
That's very inspiring.
So when you decided to cut out or carve
out three hours a day for yourself,
what was the first ship that you
eliminated?
Literally just saying no to the request
for my time.
Like what kind of Shit?
Hey,
yet Jessica,
can you take,
can you,
um,
do you think you can meet me for lunch?
I want to talk to you about an a
business idea that I have,
uh,
in the beverage space.
I know that you had your coconut water.
I want to talk to you about that.
No,
I'm going for a run,
you know?
Oh No,
I don't want any money.
I just want to talk to you for 15
minutes.
A friend of mine.
No,
you think on Friday night you can come
down for fifth and see this?
No,
because it's cumulative.
It's not one or I mean,
listen,
I made my one person ever,
no,
it's going to be one person every day or
so with some new requests.
So that was the first shift.
And the second thing is for the,
and I put myself first,
you know,
in a,
in a lot of times I don't,
but in certain times I do.
And um,
I realized that I was,
this is kind of,
maybe might be a little bit more
specific,
but I realized I love football.
I'll watch a lot of football,
man.
I realized that I was watching two
games,
the college game on Saturday,
fantasy football Sunday.
I'm locked in Sunday night game,
Monday night,
Thursday night.
And I realized that if at this point,
if I live to be 85 80 whatever,
that would be 36,000 hours of football,
36,000 hours football,
that I'd be watching that throw in some
of the fights,
throwing some of the other stuff.
It's like I pulled out this,
took the,
the fo the plug out and I freed up these
36,000 hours and my wife said,
don't want,
what do you mean you google live in the
monastery?
I'm like,
it's 15 days,
sweetie.
I just freed up 36,000 hours.
You get the benefit of that.
I'm going for 15 days.
So I freed up the time by eliminating
stuff that like fucking didn't move the
needle.
So you stop watching football told I
still watch it,
but I mean I became very aware of it and
I'll just like,
I still watch it,
but I check in.
I'm not sitting around,
you know,
on Sunday.
And nothing wrong with it.
It's just,
it wasn't moving the needle in my
family,
my finances or my wellness.
But what about recreation?
Does recreation time is that valuable?
Like enjoying things like sitting back
and watching a good movie enjoying?
Absolutely,
and I do.
I do,
but I'm not,
I'm not,
you know,
I'm asking for myself as much as I'm
asking for you.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I think,
look,
you gotta be happy and do the things you
like to do.
But you know,
again,
for me,
I look at it,
I look at it very simply.
I got three or four buckets.
I got my family and my wellness plan,
my finances and causes that are
important to me.
And you know,
if it's not moving the needle in those
four buckets,
it's really just a distraction.
Honestly.
Now that doesn't mean I'm not going to
go to a movie.
That's family.
That's,
well,
it's part of my wellness,
relaxing as part of my wellness.
You want to go,
but you know,
um,
those are kind of,
everything else kind of gets to know,
like going to lunch to,
to look at someone else's idea and a
category I don't really know much about
because they want to maybe get to me or
they weren't my wife.
No,
no,
no.
I should make a tee shirt.
I've said,
listen,
I get it.
When I was starting out as an
entrepreneur when I was 20 years old,
you know,
and I was cleaning kiddie pools and
through in the music business I was
doing all this stuff.
I laugh at a lot of jokes that were
funny.
I know what you mean.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
To get deals to get stuff out of La
Laugh and I'm sick of laughing at jokes
than on funny.
That's actually very funny.
Like you saying that it's very funny.
It's a smart thing to do.
But in the beginning it's very hard,
right?
Because you're trying to get momentum,
you're trying to establish
relationships.
You're,
you want people to like you.
You don't want to dead face a stupid
joke that have people go,
fuck that Jesse Guy,
that guy's a dick and I'm not doing
anything with it.
Yeah.
So you laugh.
Hmm.
So do you organize your time like very
specifically now and did you do that in
the past?
I do now.
I did it in the past cause you know,
in the path I do it,
I'm a do anything.
I say yes to two action things without
really thinking them through very often.
Right now what I do is I have a third
grade,
three year old system.
I have two notebooks.
I'm kind of old school.
I don't really operate well keeping
stuff and phones.
I just take everything that comes into
my head and I put it on.
I'd dump it out in my head to free up
space in my head.
So I have one journal that has
everything I need to do and I just do
that to get it out of my head.
So I don't have to remember that I have
to get my son's friends eight year old
birthday present for Saturday.
I just write it down.
It doesn't mean it goes away,
but it's out of my head.
Right.
And then I have my daily from that list
I picked the most important things that
have to get done.
And then I know the night before I write
them down or,
or the beginning of the week,
I just knock them out man.
And how long ago was it that you went to
this monastery and did this fear?
The year ago,
one year ago,
and has this enthusiasm or this feeling
waned at all?
No.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
Do you think you conveyed that in the
book?
I do.
I mean,
I,
I've been living,
I feel like I've been living my life
like this even before the monastery just
reinforced a lot of things.
I think combined with the fact that for
some reason,
you know,
I'm turning 50 it's had,
it's fucking with me in a way that I
didn't think it would.
And I don't know how you,
how old are you?
50 yeah.
So I don't know if you had the same
impact on you,
but like,
you know,
there's not a day that goes by where I
don't say to myself,
man,
in 30 years you're turning 81 to look at
live with urgency and you know,
all those,
my enemies,
the clock,
I feel like my enemies,
the Klopp and there's a lot of stuff I
want to do in my life and my enemy is
the clock.
Do you feel like you live in the moment
enough?
Absolutely.
You do?
I do.
Because that would be the worry,
right?
Like if you're constantly worrying
about,
damn,
20 years,
I'm going to be 70 30 years,
I'm going be 80.
If you keep doing that,
like there,
there are people that look ahead too
much and don't just,
I've,
I've talked to people that are 20 like,
fuck,
I can't believe I'm 20.
And I'm like,
listen Motherfucker,
you just turned 20 dude,
relax.
You know,
just 20,
you're a baby.
Naw Man,
I'm going to be fucking 30 and 10 years.
Like you shut the fuck up.
You're 20 now.
I use it as a motivator.
And I remember,
I remember when,
how,
when I was starting out.
I was 21 years old.
This is a crazy story.
Uh,
I just got dropped from our record
label.
I was signed to a record label called
delicious vinyl.
How do you do as I'm,
as I had a rap record on the way,
she's a rapper.
I was a rapper signed to delicious with
Tone Loc and Young Mc.
Oh,
get the fuck outta here.
So my album doesn't get picked.
I don't get picked up for a second
album.
And I moved to New York City.
I have two things on my resume,
Kiddie pool attendant cause I was a
kiddie pool attendant and rapper.
So I'm staying on my friend's couch,
living on his couch with his roommate
and he tells me on Monday I got to get
out of the apartment.
So instead of going to look for a new
apartment over the weekend,
I go to my friend's Bachelor Party on
the Jersey Shore.
I'm at the Bachelor Party,
I'm getting a drink at the bar and I see
this girl.
I started chatting with her.
She asked me where I live.
I told her actually as of Monday,
I have nowhere to go.
She takes out a Napkin.
She writes her address on the Napkin.
I'm 21 years old and she says,
if it's an emergency on Monday and
you're stuck,
you can come live with me.
Monday comes,
I get kicked out of my friend's
apartment.
I have nowhere to go.
I'm like,
this is an emergency.
I take out the Napkin and I live with
this girl and her roommate for six
months.
Turns out that her father is a big
entrepreneur business man.
He owns a piece of the Yankees,
dislike monster mogul.
I write this song for the New York
Knicks called go New York.
Go and it becomes a big success.
You remember that song?
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
That's okay.
I'm not a sports fan.
That's fine.
It becomes a big hit and I just realized
that there's an opportunity to write
theme songs for all these professional
sports teams,
but I don't have a penny to go in the
studio to do the demos,
to shop them to the team.
So I need money.
So I go to this music guy and he says,
I'll give you $10,000 to go and do these
songs for 10% of everything you make for
the rest of your life.
He wants to buy me like a style of the
rest of your life.
I'm 21 he's like the rest of them.
I see life.
Everything you do,
I will invest in you own an airplane
business.
He owns 10% yes.
Forever.
Yes.
You have to kill him then.
Yeah.
You have to kill that guy,
but I need the 10 grand.
So I say,
I'll take it.
So before I take it,
I go to this girl's father for this
business mogul.
Then I'm living with her and I sit down
and I'd go to this guy's apartment
again.
I'm 21 he's got in his apartment,
he's got a swimming pool,
artwork like fancy fuck women.
He's macked out,
man.
It's like,
I've never seen anything like this in
Manhattan,
in Manhattan.
I'm just setting the stage of the
conversation.
And I go in and I tell him the story
about the 10% and he says to me,
I would trade,
this is exactly what he said to me.
I will trade everything that I have if
you'd get out of my daughter's life.
Exactly.
Automate everything I have for the one
thing that you have.
And I'm like,
man,
I'm fucking broke.
What he taught me,
I go,
what's that?
And he said,
youth,
because he had already gone through the
journey,
even though he had everything,
he already had gone through the process.
He wasn't that 20 year old that you're
talking about,
that whatever he had gone through it,
he had it all.
He Wa he wa he missed the process,
the journey of being you coming up at 20
and not know like,
you know,
here you are.
But it was that,
those were the years,
man,
right?
The first fight,
the first this like that.
That's what,
that's what makes you like so,
and that stuck with me,
man.
At 21 years old,
it's stuck with me and realize that
like,
man,
I got to enjoy the process and it's
really never rubbed off on me in front
of me.
Oh,
well why didn't that guy,
how old was this guy at the time?
The old rich dude,
he was,
let's see,
he must have been his sixties when they
just do shit to a bunch of shoot day
lounging around his fucking swimming
pool.
Did he did,
he had an amazing man.
He was 20.
He had an amazing life.
So what did you wind up doing?
Uh,
he said the SEC,
the second part of that conversation,
he said,
do you,
um,
will you make this work on your own?
I said,
I think I can.
He said,
I didn't ask you if you can.
I said,
he said,
will you make it work?
I said,
well,
he said,
and then go tell the guy to fuck off and
make it and it goes and go make it work.
And I did.
So how'd you get it funded that uh,
I,
I somehow got,
I went to the Dallas Mavericks after the
Knicks and told them that I convinced
them to give me a $2,500 the next pay
me.
This is the crazy part of my life,
but they gave me $2,500 to do the demo
and then they bought the song for like
$20,000 and that funded the rest of the
business that I ultimately sold to a
public company.
Wow.
That's crazy.
And you almost gave away 10% of your
whole life.
That guy wanted 10% is a piece of shit.
What a mother fucker like.
That's a,
it's just business drives prisoners and
I had no one to go to,
but I know he's taken advantage of a 21
year old kid who's just got some dreams
and need some cash and 10 grand to hims,
probably nothing.
I called my father and my father
owned the plumbing supply house in
Mineola Long Island and I during this
time in my thing and my father said,
you know,
I love him to death,
but he's like,
you know,
do it.
Do what you think is best.
He just didn't,
you know,
I didn't know who to turn to.
I had no one to turn to.
Yeah,
don't,
don't give up 10% of your life.
Right.
That was just crazy that someone asks
for that.
But you hear things like,
I mean,
this is similar to what they do in the
music business,
like how the music business treats
artists.
They essentially sign you to these
contracts and then take a piece of
everything.
They take a piece of,
if you do a movie,
they take a piece of your live
performances,
your merchandise sales,
everything.
They just say,
look,
we'll,
we'll help you out a little bit,
but you know,
we want you,
right?
Yeah.
I mean at least you're in a contract
though,
but there's some creepy contracts that
they used to do in the old days of
Hollywood that were similar to that.
Right.
They just take a pcf forever.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
when I signed my music deal,
I didn't care.
I was like,
you can take whatever you want,
man.
Get me on MTV.
Right.
Of course.
Yeah.
Cause did all,
well,
that's the whole idea there were the
reason why these exploitation contracts
work is because in the beginning you're
just so desperate and what you have is
what they don't have.
You have talent,
right?
You have,
as you're creative,
you're young and full of energy and
you've got something exciting that
people want to look at.
And so what they do is they go,
oh,
you will look,
we gotta fucking,
we got to wade through the door,
but we want 75% of the profits.
We want a little bit of this and,
and you don't get any money back until
we recoup our money that we spent on
executives and parking and car leases
and they calculate all that shit.
How much the fucking building costs,
how much the electricity,
all that stuff.
They cow.
If you've seen those,
I'm sure.
Oh yes.
Contracts.
They're fucking sign them.
I've sat in on my own way.
Yeah.
But um,
you know,
it's part of the process and no
leverage,
no leverage.
That's the thing.
They've got the leverage,
but now and now they don't have
delivered,
but they still figure out a way to pull
it off.
It's really weird because who the fuck
is buying an albums now?
No one,
no one.
Right.
Yet these record companies are still
figuring out how to cling on,
do you like a lamprey?
Suck blood out.
There's still staying alive and they're
fat fingers driving their fat Mercedes
Benz.
They know how to do it.
They just figured out a way to grab
people that are just,
just getting poppin,
you know,
and just sign it and then figured out a
way to get in with these fucking
streaming companies.
If you paid attention to that shit a
little bit.
Yeah.
That's the darkest.
It's even darker than the music
distribution because the artists get
like no money point.
Oh yeah.
Steven Tyler was talking about it with
me.
It's just,
he was explaining it and there's a,
there's,
it's the company's actually,
or the organization is actually called m
m a what is it?
Something,
what did it stand for?
Musicians for,
uh,
some,
some sort of an act where they're,
you know,
trying to stop these streaming companies
from ripping off these artists' music
modernization act.
Yeah.
It's dark.
But it's along the same lines.
It's like people figuring out a way to
just take something from somebody
because you need it.
You know,
you're broke,
you're desperate.
You're,
so,
you signed a contract.
Oh,
we've got to by contract.
And as soon as they then music that was
invented,
like how they put led Zepplin on the
streaming service.
You know,
they,
there was no streaming when that this
should be a whole new contract.
Right.
I don't know.
It's true with audio books too,
you know,
I mean,
even bucks now and all these old
publications,
they never envisioned that there would
be,
you know,
I ebooks and audio books and all these
different distribution areas.
I would imagine that audio books
probably mirror the sales of regular
books now.
I know.
So,
I mean,
at least in my circle,
I know so many people who just use audio
books and they hardly ever hardly ever
read.
And what they've essentially done is
taken that commuter time that was just
dead air and filled it up with books.
I can't,
when,
when I,
when seal,
when I put it the seal book,
I couldn't believe how many people hit
me about the audio because I did my own
audio book and I just couldn't,
I didn't even hear was that came out two
years ago.
Hmm.
And it just never dawned on me that
people even listen to audio books when
it may be angry that I did the read so
quickly.
I was like,
I should have invested a little bit more
time like gotten a coach or something.
Right.
You know,
I just like read it.
What percentage of your books were audio
versus paper?
It's a good question.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Guess about 30% 30 to 40 maybe
40 30 40%.
So it's closing in closing in on 50
because you know,
people can now speed it up a little bit
so they can get through it quicker and
you can do it when they're,
you know,
when you do that with podcasts,
right.
So listeners when frankly,
I don't know,
Lola do listen to us right now.
Like we're on speed.
Yeah.
Now when you are done with this book
and you know,
you,
you get back from this monk thing and
you realize that this is made like some
sort of a fundamental shift in the way
you live your life and you put this book
out.
Is there a real sense that people who
read this book are going to get that
from you?
And,
I mean,
are you aware that you're probably going
to change the way a lot of people live
their lives?
I hope so.
I mean,
I just,
I don't know if they'll change the lies,
but I think it,
I hope,
I hope that it helps them look through
things through a different Lens,
you know,
and you know,
make their own decisions.
You know,
one of the takeaways from the book isn't
so much a specific around the monastery.
It's around this notion of building your
life resume,
you know,
and just stepping into the unknown.
Because to me,
that's,
for me,
that's where I learned the best thing
you could.
I could get a traditional coach or go to
seminars or experts,
but I just don't learn.
I learned by going into the unknown and
I hope it just,
it just motivates people to have a
little bit more urgency and do stuff
like that.
You don't have to go to a monastery,
but you know,
there's an old Japanese ritual,
you might be familiar with it,
I don't know,
called the Ms Sogi.
And the thought around them is Sogi is,
it was introduced to me by Kyle Korver
played at the hawks for the Atlanta
Hawks.
And the,
uh,
the notion around the Muskogee is you do
something so hard one time a year that
it has an impact the other 364 days of
the year on you that you go so far
beyond.
You know,
for me that was my hundred mile run.
I mean,
I can look back since 2008.
I've had moments like that every year,
but um,
though,
and I believe in that,
I believe in that and um,
in the widest brought that up.
But,
but it's true.
And,
um,
so it's just kind of one of the themes
around this urgency and,
and you know,
creating memories,
et cetera.
You know,
I think there's things like that sort of
highlight that urgency that if you just
live your life like at the same steady
static pace and maybe sometimes you
don't feel it as much,
like,
like I'm sure after you did your hundred
mile run,
like when it was over,
you probably,
it probably felt so good to relax.
Ah,
well first of all,
for me,
the,
the pressure around completing the run.
When I did the run,
I raised millions of dollars for charity
and everyone in my world knew I was
doing it.
I gave myself 90 days to train for.
It isn't what's normal.
I would say like for the people in the
shape that I was in going into it
probably a year,
eight months,
six months.
I mean,
whoa.
I mean I gave myself 90 days.
I started in August and the,
the race was 90 days later and uh,
everyone in my world was donating or
involved or knew about it.
So if I didn't finish it,
so much can go wrong in a hundred mile
run.
You know,
like if something goes wrong in a
marathon at mile 19,
you've got it out.
You've got seven more miles,
you know,
something goes wrong at Mile 1981 miles
left.
You can't gut,
most people can't cut that out.
I don't think I could.
I felt so relieved when it was done
because I was just like,
man,
I did it and no one can take it away
from me.
What was the longest you would root rote
and not written?
Uh,
ran before that I ran two 50s,
two fifties to 50 milers.
I mean,
I never did miles at a time,
so I did two 10 hour,
10 hour runs twice and 50 miles in those
10 hours probably around there,
somewhere around there.
So,
but you knew that you were at the
halfway mark roughly and you could push
through the rest?
I knew that if I got to 50 mile,
if I could get to,
um,
50 miles and 10 hours,
I could basically even injured walk the
rest,
the allocated time.
Now after that was over and after he did
do the 100 miles,
how much of a shift did that make in the
way you thought about time and effort?
Totally changed my life completely,
completely talking about this Miss Sogi,
it completely changed my life.
That was in 2006.
I think that I did the run and it's
completely changed my life because when
I started running,
my goal was to run two miles.
If I could run two miles in 18 minutes,
nine minute pace,
I consider myself a runner and I work
towards that goal.
Like out of college,
I was like,
just got out of college.
I'm going to try to run two miles,
you know,
like it took me a little to get there in
[inaudible] nine minute pace.
And um,
fast forward I ran this.
Nothing in my body changed,
does the same legs.
God gave me same lugs God gave me.
I'm not very strong,
nothing's changed.
But I took that two mile body and ran a
hundred miles and I bet almost a lot of
people that are listening this could run
two miles and with a gun to their head,
they could run two miles that they had
to.
And the only thing that changed was the
way I perceive what I thought I could do
in this run.
And I realized after the race that Holy
Shit,
I did 50 acts,
what my initial goal was like I was
under indexing 50 x in this category of
my life.
What are the areas of my life,
Jesse?
What other areas of your life,
man,
are you under indexing in like,
okay,
if you're a sales quota at Marquis jet,
my company was 20 jet cards.
Is that cause I knew I could get it and
it was comfortable or should I be like
I'm putting you on the board for 40
fellows this month.
Let me see what the fuck I can do.
Right.
I was living in this like comfort.
I was going through life like this
routine and routines are great,
but routines can also be a Rut.
You can't get better in a routine.
And if you get,
so when you're in a routine,
time goes fast.
When you're adding your routine time go
slow.
So I was so comfortable in my routine.
It was like,
man,
fuck it.
I don't want to go through life like
this.
I want to go through life like this.
You know?
And I was,
people were listening.
You were going up.
I'm going to host.
People are listening.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm scrolling fun.
I'll do this all the time.
I'm just locked.
I don't even know where people are
listening.
Yeah,
I'm locked into you.
I was going flat.
You know,
I was just doing the same shit and I
want a nice 45 degree upward angle.
Yeah.
So this,
this run showed me,
man,
I was under indexing so much what I
thought I was capable of and it made me
think like,
what else am I capable of?
What about recovery?
Like what was it like when you were
done?
Well,
at Mile 94 I realized I had toenails in
my show.
So that was an uncomfortable feeling.
And when I felt them felting rattle
around and when I took my shoes off,
my feet were so fucked up.
Is it because your feet swell while
you're running and you,
if you have like a size 10,
you're supposed to swap out to a size 11
later.
That's what works.
I swapped,
I want to size up,
but I blisters,
I bad blisters.
My blisters were really bad and bad
before you ran or I got them as I was
going and they look like it literally
looked like I had swallowed red grapes
and they went to the bottom of each of
my toe.
I mean,
it was just so I was in a wheelchair for
four days after the race,
four days just because of the bottom of
the blisters and um,
you know,
but so for me,
for me,
it just like a regular guy.
Um,
it was,
it was a very powerful moment for me,
you know,
and uh,
it was worth,
it was worth it.
It was all well,
well,
well worth it.
Once I was done and I realize like,
I'm okay,
I'm not in shock.
I'm not dehydrated.
I'm just in super pain.
Um,
that was a great moment and I have a
regret from that race.
Like one of the biggest regrets in my
life.
Like I don't like the way I finished the
race.
I ran 99 miles the last mile,
took me 48 minutes and literally had to
like grab my shoulder,
my brothers shoulders and like I just,
if I could do it all over,
I wanted to really finish that like a
champion,
you know?
And I was just very disappointed.
I'm very happy about it.
But I also,
one of my biggest regrets from the race
is just that,
you know,
I got to that moment where,
and I just didn't finish it the way I
wanted to finish it,
what was wrong?
Oh man,
my fucking joints like my hips and my
knees were just like swollen,
just so much,
just so much pain.
They were just,
it was just so at 75 I felt,
I just kind of like was running and then
all a sudden I was on the ground because
like I just buckled because it was,
it was my joints,
not my muscles,
just like my,
you know,
like I said,
if you,
if you roll your thumb around for 24
hours,
your thumb's gonna fall off.
You know,
it's this the stop motion and pounding
and,
and I didn't know what I was wearing
cotton.
I was like,
I did everything wrong,
you know,
but I did it.
And when you did get done with that and
the wheelchair for four days,
how long did it take before your body
felt normal?
Like your joints normalized your hips
and your knees and took about two over a
little over two weeks.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you just hobbling around for two
weeks thinking about it.
I'm still impacted by it really?
How so?
I like a huge cyst,
like from all the stress on my,
on my foot that,
um,
I've had like a ham sized,
when you say it,
you're like,
fuck,
you're holding.
You see like you have a skull on?
Like how big was it?
Like big enough.
I couldn't wear shoes.
Why don't I wear sneakers that like,
yeah,
it was,
I'll show you a picture.
I got a drain twice and then I went to
like a real,
like a almost fruitarian diet and went
away.
Fruitarians just all fruit.
Why did that do it?
I uh,
I don't know.
I,
yeah,
I used to try fruits with vegetables or
fruits with anything else.
So for 27 years I've only had fruit till
12 o'clock noon.
That's all I eat in the morning.
But I extended that out further and it
went away on its own from fruit.
I don't know if that's the reason.
Maybe over a month just went away.
Um,
but I made some significant changes in
my diet.
Yeah.
So what,
but what led you to be the fruitarian
idea?
Uh,
I read a book called fit for life when I
was 20.
Right.
For my first marathon,
I was 21 or 22 years old.
Like looking for an edge.
And in the book it challenges the reader
to,
uh,
try to eat.
One of the principles of the book is to
only fruit until noon and we can talk
about it,
but,
uh,
it challenges the reader to try it for
10 days and then day 11,
go back to regular breakfast and see how
you feel.
So I did like,
I can invest 10 days to try this.
And on day 11,
I went back to oatmeal and toast or
whatever and I was like,
oh my God,
man,
I felt so sluggish and like bloated and
I was like,
I never went back.
And it's,
and that,
that's unwavering.
I'm unwavering on that.
I've run marathon and never changes
fruit until noon.
And um,
so that's why now what are these people
eat in the monastery?
So they have a very light breakfast that
suited me.
Well,
they have fruit in the morning and then
their lunch,
they called dinner,
that's their big meal.
So the afternoon,
noon meal was sup is like dinner and
then at night it was super light,
like soup and salad or whatever it is
really like almost one meal a day.
Are they vegetarian?
Uh,
somewhere,
but others weren't.
That's interest.
Not all of them were,
which was,
which was interesting.
Did you expect them to be?
I did.
I lost a lot of weight there.
I lost like 17 pounds.
15,
17 pounds.
Yeah.
Weeks.
Why so what do you think it's lack of
sugar?
No carbs.
Lack of sugar.
One meal a day.
They don't eat any bread or they did.
I didn't,
I wanted to put a little asterisk next
to my thing.
I went,
I went in there saying to myself,
I didn't want to have,
I wanted to come back clean.
So I really try not to have any grains.
And I did have some grains,
but not,
not a lot.
And I walked a lot.
I walked 120 miles over the,
over the time I was there up and down
the driveway.
And uh,
so I lost a lot of us,
a lot of weight.
I gained it all back,
but at the time,
yeah.
Now these people that live this life,
do they have something they're working
towards?
Do they have an idea that they're
working towards?
Does it mean when you,
when you press them on it and ask them
like,
why are you here?
Do you ever plan on leaving?
Do you ever see yourself going somewhere
else?
That's a really good question.
I asked them all those questions.
So,
uh,
no.
They felt like that was their calling,
their calling.
They were doing what they were supposed
to be doing and um,
that they were committed to that
lifestyle.
So no,
they weren't,
there was no thought of going back.
There had been monks that have left the
monastery,
just wasn't the right lifestyle for
them.
But the monks that were there when I was
there,
you know,
50 years they were committed and they're
not going anywhere.
When you say that's what's confusing to
me,
like I understand that they're enjoying
and I understand that they're,
they,
they liked that life,
but that it's a calling,
like the calling to do nothing or just
think maybe it's just sacrifice.
Serve God,
um,
live a life of purity.
This is not right.
I understand.
I couldn't do it,
but I think that's kind of the mindset
around it.
And,
um,
step away from
the regular life that they were living.
What's interesting is that they weren't
born into the monastery,
right?
A lot of these guys made this decision
in their twenties,
thirties,
you know,
so what were their jobs before they did
it all over the board,
all over the board.
Literally,
uh,
one guy,
I mean,
one of the most of the lifeguard as a
teenager.
Wow.
I mean,
just all over the board.
So,
um,
but regular jobs just always felt
connected to God and connected to this
higher living a life just,
you know,
under these terms.
But what's fascinating to me is that
you're saying that there was so happy
because if you get a rent,
I mean,
how many,
how many people were in this monastery?
Uh,
eight and they're all male.
Yes.
Eight men.
If you get eight random men in there,
you know,
what's the young stage of the guys?
35 35 up to 70 you get eight random 35
to 70 is now is how many of them are
happy?
Actually truly happy,
maybe too,
right?
How many people do you think are happy?
Well,
they just did a study as a famous Harris
study on happiness in this country.
I think 67% of people are unhappy that
it's fucked.
Here's what here I did this jail,
you'll,
this is a good test.
Maybe you'll want to do this.
I did this when I was speaking at an
event for 500 Wall Street people
recently and it was fascinating.
I'll take you through it.
You can tell me if you're comfortable
with it,
but if you take all the areas of your
life and put them in a blender,
okay,
so take a,
where you live,
your relationships,
your finances,
your health,
everything,
everything.
Put it in one fucking big blender and
blend it up.
And on a scale of one to 10 with 10
being the Dalai Lama of happiness and a
one being a guidance at rock was zero
being some of us at rock bottom.
What your happiness number
me?
Yeah,
I'm pretty fucking happy.
Well I don't know.
I wouldn't do it that way.
I definitely wouldn't give it a number.
Okay.
Cause I feel like that you're,
you're making something,
you're,
you're turning like
a constant state of thinking and
expression and consideration.
You're turning it into a number and I
just,
I don't like that idea.
I don't like that idea because I think
it's a management issue.
I think a lot of what happiness is a
management issue and decisions that
you're making right now.
Like you could be in a shit state of
mind right now,
but you can make some decisions to
adjust that and over the next couple
hours you'll get to a much better place.
And these constant management decisions,
they waver in and out of your life on a
daily basis.
Like this idea that you could have a
good mindset,
then all of a sudden you'll be happy.
That's horse shit.
Like it's that's like,
it's like the tide,
it comes in and it comes out and there's
going to be days where you're just not
feeling so good physically and that's
going to affect the way your happiness
level is.
It's never static.
It's never the exactly the same.
True.
But if you look at it overall at 30,000
feet and you had to give yourself a
grade,
he's happy as fuck is what I would say.
Happy.
Okay.
So I'll take that.
I'll take that.
Most people in that room,
yeah,
raised there.
I said if anyone is seven and you know
for anyone that listening that wants to
do it,
raise your hand if you're,
you know,
seven or below.
I don't want to put anyone on the spot.
And majority of the room stood up.
Right.
Being a seven and thinking,
you know like seven's pretty happy
number but a seven if my son comes home
with a 70 on a test to see minus.
Right.
And all I'm saying is,
but what was interesting about the test
though,
if you do actually go through the
process for those that like go through
and get a number in their head or
whatever,
do you want to give their self a grade?
Your brain automatically goes to a 10
and then subtracts the two or three
things pop in that make you better bring
you happiness down.
It's a great way to identify what's
making you unhappy and that,
you know what I mean?
Like it started at 10 you're like,
oh fuck my relationship or this or that.
Usually it triggers an automatic,
like this is what's fucked up in my life
response,
and you can,
it helps you identify,
but it's interesting.
We have benchmarks and so many things in
our life.
You have an Iq test,
you have tax brackets to measure your,
your wealth or financial statements.
You have Iq tests.
Like I said,
you can get on a scale to measure your
weight,
but you're right.
Happiness is one of those things.
It's like how do you benchmark it?
You know what I mean?
It kind of fluctuates.
It's like hunger.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's something that's go,
it goes in and out.
It's always there.
But happy as fuck is a,
is a good answer.
But I,
this is something I've cultivated for a
long time and avoided things that make
me unhappy and figured out what those
things are and been very rigid about
eliminating them from my life.
And one of the big ones is
interactions with people that are
negative.
That is gigantic.
And B,
because I realized that I'm not really
as independent as I used to,
like to think I was,
I used to like to think that my thought
process was independent and that I don't
give a fuck what anybody thinks.
That's nonsense.
People say that because they absolutely
care what people think and it bothers
them.
So they say,
I don't give a fuck,
but that I don't give a fuck.
Stuff is almost entirely nonsense.
You do care and you care in both ways.
You care if people critical of you've
care if people are positive you,
but you also care if people are living
positive lives and they're motivating
you.
That's,
that's a big one.
People are fuel and other people.
It's one of the reasons why I like
talking to people.
One of the reasons why I like to do
podcasts because I get a lot out of,
you know,
like just talking to you about your time
in the monastery or you're,
you're pushed to get to that hundred
miles.
Like you get energy out of people like
that and you think about this energy and
you think about this inspiration when
you're doing other things.
And it also sets in your mind that when
you meet these exceptional people that
move you,
like what are the characters?
What are the qualities that they have?
What are the characteristics that they,
that they possess?
And those things become significant and
important to you.
Whereas if you live around a bunch of
people that are complaining and bitching
about everything and they see the
negative in everything and they're
always whining,
those people are the opposite of that.
They're the opposite of inspiration and
they're,
they're just there.
They're mud and you're just like,
whoa.
It's like you're up to your ankles and
bud,
you try to trudge through life.
It's difficult.
You're not light.
It's not,
it's not pushing it.
It's not a wind at your back,
the winds in your face.
And it's rough,
you know?
And over time I've learned that these
people,
you just,
you're not going to fix him.
I used to want to fix someone.
I was young,
I used to want to go,
hey man,
I see what you're doing.
Like,
dude,
don't do that anymore.
Listen,
just try it.
Just,
just do this and,
and stop doing that and start doing
this.
And if you just work towards this,
you could be successful.
And then a week later the guys doing the
same shit and you're like,
okay,
I'm wasting a significant amount of my
energy on someone who doesn't want to
waste any of their energy on themselves.
And so managing the,
the community and the tribe that you're
in,
making sure that you're a good member of
that tribe,
that your doing your part,
you know?
And there's a lot of cynicism in these
days about inspiration and about
motivation because there's a lot of fake
shit.
You know,
you can go on instagram and you see a
million of these inspirational quote
pages and there were run by people that
are probably depressed.
You know,
you see a lot of people that are,
you know,
talking about how to get ahead in life,
but they're not really doing anything
themselves.
So there's a lot of cynicism involved in
that.
But there's also sincerity in it and you
can get,
if you just look at it with a pure heart
and a pure mind,
you can get a lot of energy out of that.
And when you're around happy,
inspirational people that are
successful,
it makes you feel better and you get
inspired.
And if you act on that inspiration,
your life will be more fulfilled.
And it's not just inspirational in terms
of financial success,
but in terms of doing difficult things,
whether it's running a hundred miles,
it doesn't pay you a God damn thing
other than the the,
the wealth of the knowledge that you can
push yourself to such an extreme or
anything else.
Whether it's someone who becomes a
really good at playing chess or someone
who's really good at martial arts or,
or whatever it is,
there's,
there's a great feeling in these
overcoming these difficult things
because life is never this just constant
state of I'm at a nine all day and when
I'm with my wife,
I hit 10 Yay.
And I stay like that.
That's not real.
What's real is like you saying that you
went to this monastery and felt all
this,
this angsty about meditating and being
alone and not having your phone and not
having the input.
But then when it comes out of it,
then you have this reward.
So you,
you pushed through this and you had
these uncomfortable feelings and you
came out of those uncomfortable feelings
with this new found appreciation for
time and this new found respect for your
own existence in your own space and
carving out three hours for yourself a
day.
That's where it all comes from.
It all comes from life lessons and the
lessons are learned through struggle and
I think that there's a lot of people out
there that thinks somehow or another
you're going to get to some place where
you're living in silk sheets and you get
your toes done while someone's dropping
grapes into your mouth.
I don't want that.
I've never wanted that.
That guy's not going to be happy.
It's going to be bored our into the
grapes.
You can we get those fucking grapes away
from me.
Stop painting my toes.
What am I doing in this bed?
I got to do something.
I'm not stimulated.
The human organism,
the animal that we are needs constant
stimulation because it evolved.
Trying to find food and escape enemies
and find shelter,
escape nature,
escape the elements,
try to survive.
And this is the great joy that you
haven't taken care of your children,
that you can protect your children from
the elements and the enemies and feed
them and,
and it's also the great sadness that you
see in losers.
When I see a loser,
I see some guys,
43 years old,
lives in his parents' basement and he
fucking hates the world.
I'm like,
that was a baby man.
This is a baby that somebody just gave
shitty nutrients to.
Whether its nutrients in the forms of
food or in the form of thoughts and
ideas and examples and this kid develop
these horrible self defeating patterns
of behavior that have led them to this
point where they're this,
this middle aged person with no future
and no idea of how to get out of this
Rut,
probably never will escape it and might
just wind up sucking on a gun.
You know what I mean?
This is,
this is the world that we live in today
and I think part of that world is
because we have been fed this line of
Horse Shit that you're supposed to seek
comfort and I don't think you are.
I think you're supposed to seek lessons
and you supposed to seek difficult tasks
and and,
and,
and accomplishments and through those
things and through doing things that are
hard to do,
even if it's just a fucking 90 minute
hot yoga class,
I do a 90 minute yoga class,
man.
I,
those last 20 minutes,
I do not want to be there man.
And I definitely don't want to give 100%
and I can cheat.
I can,
I could kind of have acid.
but if I don't and I get through it,
when that time is up and the lady says
Namaz Day and everybody gets up,
I'm like,
fuck man,
I made it,
you know,
I lost 15 pounds.
My fucking Yoga Mat is drenched to the
point where I can literally wring it out
and fill up a jug up with water.
But through that struggle,
I will now have a better day and I
better fucking do it again tomorrow or
do something else because if I just
think,
well tomorrow I'm just going to coast
and eat twinkies and watch TV.
Oh,
hello sadness,
my old friend.
Hello Depression.
Because when you're not doing anything
you feel like shit and that's just part
of being a human being and we can
pretend that we're something other than
what we really are and we can pretend
not me,
man.
I'm just cool.
Just chilling,
doing nothing.
Bullshit.
You're a fucking human.
You're a human being.
You,
you evolve from the fucking hundreds and
thousands of years of hunters and
gatherers and people that were
struggling.
Those real human reward systems are
carved deeply into your DNA.
And if you don't respect that,
if you don't respect the mechanism of
happiness and fulfillment and what you
really need to do in order to feel
satisfied in life,
camaraderie,
love,
family,
friendship,
struggle,
testing yourself,
learning,
all those things are imperative.
They're all a giant part of being a
person.
I love it.
That was amazing.
And I,
I'm thinking in my head and my checking
those boxes as you're talking and in my
living my life like that,
you know?
And uh,
yeah,
I agree with you.
It sounds like you are.
I am.
Yeah.
No,
I feel like,
oh,
waiver,
right.
We all have days in and days out.
Absolutely.
But to be reinforced.
Yup.
And I'm a,
I feel like,
you know,
as I'm listening to you talk about that,
I'm literally going through like the
last 10 years of my life,
you know?
And when I live with David,
when I went on the modest as all of
these things,
um,
they're all about getting an edge and
doing what you,
you know,
and it is,
it's,
I think it's like part of being human
and that stuff makes me feel most the
most alive too.
You know?
Like it just makes me feel alive.
Yeah.
You know,
and also like little improvements over
things.
It's why doing difficult things as good,
whether it's running.
So like if you're running and you run,
you could run two miles and then one day
you get it up to three.
So like fuck,
I remember when I struggled with too,
now I can do for little improvements,
you know,
and you really that in yoga class and in
particular for me because I'm not good
at it,
you know,
so when I do a yoga class and I can hold
a pose until the night,
you know like you're holding these pose
for a minute and if you could stand on
one foot,
grabbing your other foot,
lifting it above your head and keep your
arm out straight and your balance and
your foot's on fire and your core is
engaged.
But if you can get to the point where
they say stop you,
you've,
you feel like,
wow,
I didn't used to be able to do that.
I used to be able to hold it for 10
seconds and I would fall down and then
I'd have to start all over again.
Start from scratch.
There's little improvements.
Will you feel yourself getting a little
better at something,
whether it's Jujitsu or anything else,
little improvements I think or what life
is all about.
And I think also there,
there are a tool to feed the mind cause
I really believe the mind needs these
little lessons.
The mind needs these little,
these little tasks.
And if you,
your brain doesn't get that,
I think it atrophies and it gets
depressed and it's like,
it's like,
I think that's half of what a lot of
people's sadness is,
is this lack of stimulation and reward,
lack of these peaks and valleys.
And this again,
this bullshit idea that we're constantly
fed,
that you should be comfortable.
It's so true.
I mean,
when,
when Goggins live with me,
his rule is we had to do something
everyday that sucked.
That was his role.
And he's the master at that Shit.
Tell me about it.
And when did he make you do?
Uh,
everyday sucked.
He didn't tell me that we're going to do
that five times a day.
That what,
you know?
Um,
no.
I mean,
I remember one day Bob was,
the first thing we did was we,
he came in and he um,
he wanted to see how many pull ups I
could do so we can map out the month.
He lived with me for a month and I went
to the pull up bar and I got like maybe
eight pull ups,
which is an exaggeration.
I'm probably got like four pull ups.
A lot of people are listening.
So
uh,
and then he said,
I wait 30 seconds,
go and do it again.
And I went up on the pull up bar and I
did maybe like three or four.
He said,
I wait 30 seconds,
I want you to do it again.
And I got up on the pull up bar and I
did maybe like one kipping,
you know,
getting my damn chin over the bar and
barely,
and I dropped down.
It was all jacked up and I said,
all right,
well what's,
what's next?
He said,
well,
what's next is we're not leaving here
until you do a hundred more.
We're not leaving the gym until you do
100 more that day.
Now,
like right now,
right now.
So you and I was like seven.
I did like probably seven or 10.
And I was like,
man,
God knows that's impossible.
And he said,
you know,
I already,
I already know what your biggest problem
is and he's just like the limitations
you're putting on yourself or are self
imposed,
get the fuck back on the bar.
And you know,
Roger that then and uh,
I got up on the bar and I all over over
the course of an hour or two,
I did them.
And that started our journey of like,
you're about to go in a place where
you've never been motherfucker,
you know,
and you know,
we went,
I remember one day I was sitting on
couch and uh,
in Connecticut where I was living at the
time and on the ticker,
on the,
on the TV,
the emergency broadcast system came up,
stay inside freezing rain,
icy conditions,
high winds stay inside.
It's like beeping,
stay inside.
And Gaga was like,
this is amazing.
Now let's go for a run.
And I'm like,
they're telling us the exact opposite.
They're there,
they're broadcasting to the whole
community to stay inside.
So we go for a 10 mile run in the
blizzard and we'd come home and I lived
on a lake and kids are playing hockey on
the lake.
So we go down and he takes his hand and
he moves all the snow off the ice.
It gets a boulder and he breaks the ice,
a little hole in the ice with the
boulder.
And then he takes his hand and he mixed
the whole little bit bigger.
And then he jumps in and then he points
at me and he takes his finger and he's
singles for me to jump in.
I'm not going in the fucking freezing
cold water because my mother told me as
a kid in long island,
don't go anywhere near the frozen where
if you fall in,
you have like a minute,
you know,
he's bathing in it.
So of course I go in and,
uh,
he looks at me,
he's like,
man,
you got about,
uh,
about four to two to four minutes.
You're gonna get hypothermia.
We just went on to run.
We got to get you out of the lake and I
go to get ad,
he goes,
you can't get out.
He goes,
if your skin touches the ice,
it's going to stick to the ice.
Like the kid in Christmas story is Tang
that sticks to the pole,
you know,
so he puts my shoes back on my hands and
picks my ass up and puts my sock.
I put my socks on or whatever and I,
I could bear crawl out of the ice and I
run up and I see my wife looking out the
window as I'm running into the house and
we come in and she says to Goggins,
you know,
like,
what's the medical benefit of jumping in
a frozen lake?
And he said to her,
there's no medical benefit,
was like,
this is what your husband signed up for.
You know,
he's like,
I want to see how far he's willing to go
to get to his goals.
And I was like,
fuck,
this is going to be some 30 days.
Jesus.
Wow.
What was the toughest thing you made you
do?
Uh,
it was just the consistency of it.
You know,
it was just like,
it was just really,
he,
she went everywhere I went.
He shadowed me for 30 days.
He went to every business meeting,
we flew together.
He lived with,
you know,
with my wife.
And I did just think like,
what the fuck did I sign up for?
And this is back in 2010 so this is,
uh,
you know,
um,
yes,
I did.
I was,
and the book came out two years ago.
No,
I can't,
yeah,
I waited five years.
I didn't,
you know,
and expect it to ever be a book.
It was just like,
you know,
at all,
there was no book being discussed.
I kept a little blog about it,
you know,
so why'd you do it?
Um,
I just felt like there was so much in
it.
There's so many lessons and it was funny
fish out of water.
Like he's coming into our house.
My wife owns spanx.
I mean,
like the dual dynamic of this shit was
crazy.
And,
um,
I just felt there were a lot of lessons
that could be learned through it.
And,
um,
you know,
I just took a shot at it.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
He's a maniac.
When,
when he did the podcast,
I got here,
he showed up super early and when I got
here he was already with his shirt off
doing chin ups
and I was like,
I walked into the back where the gym is
and he's,
he's in there.
I'm like,
look at this mother fucker.
Amazing.
I he's a savage.
Yeah,
he's legit.
But these are all the lessons,
you know,
like as you're talking about,
and you don't know where the nuggets
come from.
You put yourself in a position for the
nuggets to appear and they don't have to
be radical positions.
Like,
I'm going to go get gigatons,
I'm going to go live with a ma.
Be Radical.
But you put yourself out there like you
were saying,
and you live a life with those lessons
find you.
Yeah.
And then,
and seek them.
You seek them.
Yeah.
Well Goggins story is so fascinating
because he wasn't that guy.
He was fat and out of shape and
unmotivated and lazy and you know,
talked openly about the first time he
ran,
like he quit.
He was supposed to,
you know,
ran about three quarters of a mile,
I think he said,
and quit and he was exhausted and just
drinking milkshakes and all fucked up.
And somehow or another decided he's not
going to be that guy anymore and went
180 degrees and became this intensely
motivated ironman.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was at the race.
I saw him at the race where he broke all
the bones in his feet.
You know,
I saw him,
I was at the,
I participated in that race the first
time I saw him.
That's how I met him.
And uh,
in 2007 and uh,
you know,
he broke all the bones in his feet.
He Brooks,
yeah,
he,
he was running a hundred.
I was running this race.
It was a 24 hour race as a relay team.
I was with four friends.
And the format of the races,
you know,
you run a mile.
I run a mile,
whatever team runs the most amount of
miles.
Right.
Wins the race.
He had no teammates.
That sounds like where,
where's the rest of the team?
That sounds like him.
And he weighed a lot at the time.
So I watched him wait a lot.
Was He bodybuilding at the time?
He was just beating.
It probably weighed 260 70 pounds.
Maybe one was dead lifting and all that.
Maybe,
maybe even more.
So was this the one where he ran 24
hours all around the room just to show
that he could run a hundred miles?
Want up shitting himself?
Yeah,
he told me about that.
I saw it.
I didn't know he broke all the bones in
his feet.
He broke some bones.
Yeah.
He didn't even tell me about that.
And then he ran a marathon a month
later.
Yeah,
he's a fucking animal.
Yeah.
I mean he really is.
He was telling me also the blame that to
your wife when you say he's coming to
live with you.
You don't know.
My wife
just kick us both out.
I just said it really fast,
told Saturday cause I flew out,
I flew out to meet Goggins after the
race,
you know,
I cold called them and uh,
my wife asks me how the meeting went.
And in the meeting,
you know,
I realized like I kind of wanted to get
the secret sauce,
like what the fuck,
you know?
And um,
was that the idea?
Like,
yeah,
it was like by,
by being around some such an intensely
motivated guy that you would get the
rub,
get the rub.
And I had fallen into routine I couldn't
get out of.
And I just,
you know,
like I was like,
just get me out of my routine,
man,
you know,
and I want to learn from you and that
kind of thing.
And,
um,
my wife asks me how the lunch meeting
went and I told her that,
you know,
he's come live with us.
She was like,
why?
I like lunch meeting with him.
And did you,
were you going to propose this before
the meeting?
Uh,
I went to w what happened was I went to
the meeting and,
um,
with no real agenda other than like,
I want to meet this guy,
man,
you know,
it's 2007 I want to meet them 2008
something around,
around there was 10 years ago.
And,
uh,
I was just so drawn to him,
you know,
and um,
I actually went home and then,
and then asked him to come,
you know,
live with me and uh,
and he said yes.
And then I told my wife after this guys
coming in two days,
now why did he say yes?
I mean,
isn't he busy?
Did you offer him money?
Like how did this no,
he was,
um,
uh,
he was acting,
he was still in the military at the
time.
And uh,
yeah,
I think,
um,
I don't know exactly what triggered.
I remember asking him to comment.
I remember him saying to me,
if you're crazy enough to ask a guy like
me to come live with you,
mother Fucker,
I'm crazy enough to come.
Three days later he shows up with one
bag.
No in him.
That is exactly what it would sound like
if he said it would those crazy eyes.
Jesus Christ.
Sweetie,
this is David.
Wow.
Did you give them an objective?
Do you say,
did you say why you wanted him to come
or what,
what you're dragging it out.
At that time of my life I had a,
I was,
I had just left,
I have my timeline right.
I think I just left the,
my private is private jet car company.
I had marquis jet.
I was just starting out in the Zico
coconut water business and I was in a
routine,
you know,
I was in a Rut,
not,
I was just doing the same stuff,
man.
I was so comfortable and I was just like
this calm,
shake it up man.
You know,
you can travel with me.
I got some meetings coming up,
we'll live together.
And there was no book,
there was no anything.
Right.
The book happened years later and um,
he said,
he said he would do it.
That's crazy that he just loved it.
By the way.
It was one of the best months of my
life.
I love being around him.
He's an amazing guy.
I loved,
um,
you know,
we were watching games.
We were working out.
I was going out at midnight,
three in the morning.
We were running in the blizzards.
We were reading in the morning one one
day.
He was like,
we're going to run four miles every four
hours for 48 hours.
I was like,
I got to work.
He's like,
no,
you don't.
No you don't.
You can work 40 in 48 hours or so.
I would wake up at midnight.
We started at midnight.
We would run,
let's say it took us 40 minutes and then
we would come back and we'd have,
you know,
what?
Three hours and 20 minutes of rest and
then at 4:00 AM we go again for miles.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
48 hours.
She,
Jesus Christ one time,
like I fucking a million stories.
I mean we went in the sauna and he's
like,
all right,
we're going to stay in the sauna for a,
and I'm a sauna guy.
I thought I was just on a guy by the
way.
I thought I was,
and actually this was the steam and he's
like,
we're going to stay here for 30 30
minutes,
eight ounces of water.
Okay.
We Jack it up,
it's fucking cooking in there.
It's,
I walk in,
I'm like,
holy fuck,
it's so hot in here.
He sits down,
he's whistling Dixie,
like sitting in the corner doing his
shit.
I'm like,
you know,
eight minutes into my water's gone.
I've already dragged my eight ounces of
water and about 19 minutes in,
I'm like,
God,
I got to get out.
He's like,
you can't get out.
I'm like,
no,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna pass out.
I got to get out.
He's like,
you can't get out.
I'm like,
no,
no.
And I just,
I couldn't eat.
I didn't even wait for him to say no
again cause I'm about to.
I'm about to pass out.
I can feel myself about to pass out.
I opened up the door,
all the smoke from the steam room goes
flying out of the door.
I sit right in the chair.
He comes storming out and he looks at
me.
He's like,
Oh fuck,
you don't look good.
I go,
no,
I'm going to pass out.
He goes,
we got to abort,
abort to be shit.
Like we're not doing the rest of the 30
minutes.
Like I got a pass.
And that was the only pass I got.
Cause you almost died in the sauna or
the steam was fucked.
Steam rooms different because it's
moisture and you're tying it in.
I was kicking in like the Eucalyptus and
getting cooked.
Cooked.
Yeah.
I mean you really getting cooked.
It's not like it was Sony.
You're getting like kind of dry roasted.
Well in the moisture is different.
Like you can't get as hot in a steam
rooms.
You can in a sauna.
Correct.
Yeah.
So this was a series of these,
it's the,
you know,
getting poached throughout the,
uh,
yeah.
God,
no,
he would just make these up,
like come up with these ideas.
It was just constant man.
Like I mean,
we would go to work,
we'd be sitting at work and um,
I'd have like a 30 minute break and he'd
be like,
burpee test.
Like what?
I'm at work.
He'd be like,
I want to see how many burpees you can
do in 10 minutes.
I'd be like burpee tests.
And I was like,
in the middle of work I would like get
down,
take off my,
you know,
whatever I was wearing.
I was getting like my boxers or whatever
like just to get,
and I would do as many burpees as I
could in 10 minutes and be soaking wet
and I'd walk into my next meeting and
everybody knew he was,
he was there was part of the thing.
So you explained to all these people.
Wow.
Closed every deal.
I close every deal then cause you're so
amped up.
Plus he was there.
Who's going to say news?
Fat?
More fascinated.
I walk in and they'd be like,
at the end of the day,
at the end of the meeting I'm like,
do you want to talk?
He was like,
whatever the fuck you guys we're in,
we're in.
We're in.
Wow.
That sounds
so much better than living with a monk
was just so much better.
I miss them.
Yeah,
it's you keep in touch.
Well yeah and we go,
haven't spoken.
Doing a while,
but uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I've known him since 2007 now and it's
been 10 years.
Wow.
Yeah.
I would think that that would be hard
but exciting.
Whereas the monk thing seems like the
drone of it all.
We'll just get to you.
Yeah.
And like I couldn't go back to my room
and my surroundings in the monk thing.
I was like in their world forever.
Forever.
And they live in the same way that you
did.
They have a little cell as well.
Yeah.
I actually didn't see their rooms,
but yeah,
from what I understand,
even smaller than when I was in and I
was just smaller,
smaller than this table.
Uh,
my room was about the size of this tape.
The winners were smaller from what I
understand.
Yeah.
How's it even possible bed?
There's no position isn't like just a
little bad and just go into a space with
a blackout pick up and start all over
again.
Drone.
Yeah.
No,
I think the,
the four miles every 40 minutes or
whatever the fuck it is,
or four miles every four hours.
That sounds way better.
Yeah.
That sounds crazy then at the time,
but yeah.
How'd you end it?
How did he end the 30 days?
Oh,
he left me a note on a post it thanks.
That's it.
Jesus.
That's intense.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
My goodbyes are like long hug,
changing,
exchanging shit,
planning.
Thanks.
That would be an incredible service.
Like if he wanted to do that,
just go to like billionaires and just
say,
you have to do what I tell you to do for
a month.
I've had a lot of people would do that.
I'm sure she's charged,
charged some fucking stupid amount of
money and have him live with you for a
month,
you know?
That's hard and anybody personality wise
over time,
having roommates,
it's hot.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
If you 24 seven yeah.
I mean it's hard.
Do you ever wake you up every day?
Every day he woke up.
Yup.
Come in and tap me on the shoulder.
Time to get up.
Let's do with my wife right next to me.
Jesus Christ.
It wasn't a tap tied to do this.
It was
get up,
motherfucker does.
You'd say?
Well,
at least he was courteous.
Which branch?
Certain wait,
your wife up?
Yeah.
Was your wife like what in the fun?
Loved,
she loved them.
Loved them.
But was she to you like,
what in the fuck are you doing?
She said,
your ad,
your fucking mind.
Wow.
She,
she said you're crazy.
But 30 days later you must have been in
six shape.
Ridiculous Shit.
No ridiculous.
I,
when he left,
I didn't do anything for six weeks just
to catch up.
I didn't do anything for six weeks
because I couldn't keep the intensity
up.
I just,
I couldn't do it.
I'd run a hundred miles.
I pat down,
you know,
endurance paddle races.
I've done all this shit.
I couldn't do it.
Wow.
I was just like,
why?
You know,
it was wild.
Damn.
I look back on that stuff,
man.
It's this like,
I just feel so lucky to have had the
opportunity.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
Like I said,
you're around that you're around the
best dog trainers you're around,
you know,
and I get to live with it cause my
wife's an amazing entrepreneur.
I get to live with greatness,
you know,
and just,
you go around these things and it's just
these people.
It's just the stuff that you can learn
if you allow yourself,
you know,
to listen.
You know,
I'm not a great listener.
I'm learning to be a good listener
because even like you were giving that
little monologue and he was going
through it,
I was like,
yes man,
that shit is resonating with me.
On a high level.
You put yourself in the position and
then you have to,
you have to be able to extract it and
apply it.
Yeah.
And exactly what I was saying is what
you got out of Goggins,
like you were around greatness.
You around a man who just does not
accept mediocrity and does not accept
shitty effort.
He wants everything your body can do.
And through doing that,
you just get something more out of your
mind.
You get something more out of your life.
The,
the,
those hard days,
the relaxation is earned.
You appreciate it.
Yes.
Relaxation without any effort.
It's just bullshit.
You feel proud of yourself too.
Yeah.
That's,
I think like,
you know,
it's so important to do things that make
you feel proud of yourself,
you know?
And that's when I left the monastery.
You asked me like,
you know,
how'd you feel when you got in the car?
And the,
the exact feeling was proud that you
did.
And I did it.
Wow.
This was like proud of myself.
Like I stuck with it.
I did it.
And like,
did you have a little bit of fuck that
place too?
Yes.
I'm like,
can I,
Uber eats when I get home,
I'll be like,
stop in the first five guys burgers.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Oh Man.
Well listen,
dude,
I really appreciate you coming in here,
man.
I really enjoyed talking to and likewise
fucking awesome stories.
And,
um,
and so the two books are available right
now.
Anybody could buy them.
Is there an audio of both?
Yes.
Audio books available on audible and
apple books and all that jazz,
living with a seal and living with the
monks.
Thanks a lot,
brother.
I really appreciate you,
man.
Thank you so much.
Really enjoyed it.
He had a mutual friend and um.